[Music]
one of the biggest contradictions of
massive success is when people go to
their moms their dads their brothers
sister boyfriend/girlfriend they say
listen
one day the world's gonna know who I am
one day I will have a Ferrari the land
with the Rose the Bentley the big house
the cars the backyard with the big
swimming pool and an elevator I'm gonna
put the biggest parties people are gonna
stop me at the mall mom people are gonna
stop me at the airport and take pictures
I mean take selfies with me and tell me
oh my gosh you changed my life
I'm gonna be a millionaire one day yet
instead of staying at the office on
Friday night you call your friends and
go party instead of waking up Saturday
morning to go to the gym you sleep in
till 10 o'clock instead of reading the
book on Sundays you kick back and watch
movies all day long see the reality is
very simple those who win big they do
four things right they sleep sweat wine
repeat
and they do it over and over and over
again on to their dreams become a
reality
[Music]
if you're thinking and you st. Pat
there's no way in the world it can be
that easy listen let me break it down
for you this whole concept of sleep
sweat grind repeat comes down to a few
things you got to do when you out work
you out improve you out strategize you
outlast your peers your competitors 5 10
years from now not only will you be a
rockstar in your industry but that
Ferrari that Lambo that Bentley that
rolls was that big house with the
elevator the big parties that fame the
accolades the respect all of those
things will become a reality if you
sleep sweat client repeat
[Music]